From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC
[ Silencio ]
[ Lengua extranjera ]
[ Aplausos ]
>> Buenas tardes a todos.
Un cambio de lengua,
si no les importa,
ya que el evento va
a ser en español.
Gracias por estar aquí
en esta tarde ventosa de
calentamiento global.
[ Risas ]
>> Y tenemos una audiencia conocida,
y creo que hay más puertorriqueños
aquí que en Orlando en estos
momentos y, con razón,
porque tenemos tres estrellas
boricuas aquí con nosotros.
Y vamos a honrar a nuestro
colega, Juan Carlos Quintero,
que acaba de publicar
un excelente libro.
Y para presentarlo
tenemos a dos estudios,
fantásticos y maravillosos que
están aquí, que es Rubén y Juan.
Yo, brevemente, voy a
decir algo de ellos, ¿no?,
que para nada se acerca
a lo que son,
pero lo por menos les presento
brevemente, ¿no?, su biografía.
Empiezo con Rubén Ríos Ávila,
que es director del programa de
MF en la universidad de New York y
también imparte cursos en
el programa de doctorado del
departamento de español
y portugués.
Su investigación se concentra en
los estudios queer y del Caribe.
Ríos Ávila tiene un doctorado
en la Universidad de Cornell y se
desempeñó como jefe del
departamento de literatura comparada
de la Universidad de Puerto
Rico, recinto de Río Piedras,
donde además se ungió como
decano de estudios graduados.
Ha sido profesor visitante
en distintas universidades,
incluyendo Brown, Harvard
[inaudible].
En Puerto Rico, ha sido crítico
literario en el mundo y miembro del
consejo editorial y colaborador
de la revista cultural 80 Grados.
Fue el presentador de en cinta,
un seminario sobre cine
en la televisión pública
puertorriqueña, por varios años.
Es autor de dos colecciones de
ensayo, "La raza cómica", del 2002,
el cual fue merecedor del premio
al mejor ensayo del Pen Club y de
"Embocadura", el 2003, además de
numerosos artículos en distintas
revistas y publicaciones
académicas.
Ahora voy a pasar a
nuestro segundo presentador,
que es Juan Duchesne Winter,
que es profesor del departamento de
lenguas y literaturas hispánicas de
la universidad de Pittsburg, el
cual dirigió por varios años.
Desde el 2009 ejerce como editor
general y director de publicaciones
de la revista iberoamericana,
del Instituto Internacional
de Literatura Iberoamericana.
Egresado de la universidad
estatal de New York de Stony Brook.
Es autor de importantes
libros, entre los que figuran:
"Narraciones del testimonio
de América Latina", de 1992;
"Ciudadano insano", "Ensayos
bestiales sobre la cultura y
literatura", del 2001; [inaudible],
del 2008 y "La guerrilla narrada";
"Acción, acontecimiento, sujeto",
del 2010 y son solamente
varios títulos,
porque en realidad es
autor como de 10 libros.
Su producción es envidiable.
Además, ha publicado
numerosos artículos y ensayos,
ha participado en el programa de la
televisión y en la radio pública y
fundó las revistas independientes
Posdata, Nómada y Hotel Abismo.
Su investigación, actualmente,
se concentra en la cosmopolita
de la escritura, ¿no?,
en el tono de las discusiones
sobre la ecología globales
del Antropoceno.
Asimismo, se encuentra estudiando
las expresiones indígenas de la
Amazonia colombiana, la confluencia
de la reflexión teórica y el
pensamiento político en la
literatura contemporánea y el
surgimiento de movimientos
literarios amerindios en la
península de la guajira, o sea, que
es un gran latinoamericanista real.
Y, por último, nuestro
colega Juan Carlos Quintero,
que es profesor de literatura
latinoamericana y caribeña del
departamento de español y
portugués de la Universidad de
Maryland desde el año 2000.
Y yo tengo que decir que yo estuve
en el comité que lo empleó,
no me equivoqué.
Hizo su bachillerato de estudios
hispánicos en la Universidad de
Puerto Rico, en Río Piedra y
obtuvo su maestría y doctorado en
literatura en Princeton University,
de donde somos compañeros también.
Es autor del estudio
"Fulguración del espacio,
letras de imaginario institucional
de la revolución cubana 1960-1971",
que salió en el 2013 en Beatriz
Viterbo y obtuvo el premio
iberoamericano de estudios
latinoamericanos de LASA en el 2004.
Y también es autor del libro de
ensayo de "La máquina de la salsa:
tránsitos del sabor", de
Ediciones Vértigo del 2002,
que será reeditado
este año en España.
Recibió en el 2009 la beca
John Simon Guggenheim Memorial
Foundation, para finalizar su
libro de ensayos "La hoja mar:
efecto archipiélago I", que acaba
de publicar Almenar [inaudible] y
sobre el cual conversaremos
hoy, ¿no?
También tenemos ejemplares
del libro, así que al final,
este infomertial es extra [risas];
al final pueden obtener su copia
firmada por el autor, ¿no?
Quintero Herencia ha publicado
además 4 libros de poesía,
"La caja negra de isla
negra", de 1996;
el volumen "La hilo para el
marisco: Cuaderno de los envíos",
Instituto de Cultura
Puertorriqueña, del 2002;
y premio de poesía Pen Club de ese
mismo año, "Libro del sigiloso",
de Terranova del 2012 y también
"El cuerpo del milagro" [inaudible],
del 2016, que presentamos aquí,
en la Biblioteca del
Congreso el año pasado.
Y una selección de sus poemas
apareció traducida al inglés en la
revista digital [inaudible].
So, ya ustedes tienen una idea de
quiénes están frente a ustedes.
Así que voy a llamar al
podio a Rubén Ríos Ávila,
que comienza su presentación.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Buenas tardes a todos.
Decidí leer desde acá, para poder
poner la computadora sobre el podio.
[ Silencio ]
>> ¿Se oye bien?
>> Sí.
>> Perfecto.
Le quiero dar las gracias a Aída,
al departamento de español y
portugués de la Universidad de
Maryland y a la división hispánica
de la Biblioteca del Congreso,
para esta linda oportunidad
de celebrar,
junto con Juan y Juan Carlos,
el nacimiento del último
libro de Juan Carlos Quintero,
que es un colega y
un amigo entrañable.
Esto es un ensayo apreciativo
en torno a "La hoja de mar (:
) Efecto archipiélago I".
"La hoja de mar (: )
Efecto archipiélago I",
el tercer ensayo distendido
de Juan Carlos Quintero,
tras más de 10 años de aparecida
su "Sabrosa máquina de la salsa",
se inaugura ya desde su título
bajo el signo de la poesía.
Un primer referente para
este enigmático título,
podría ser "Las hojas de
hierba", de Walt Whitman,
donde se alude por un lado,
a las hojas del libro de poemas que
estamos leyendo, un libro rústico,
propone Whitman, no de hojas de
árbol, sino de hojas de hierba,
es decir, vandeano, en menosprecio
de las cortes y las capillas de la
institución literaria
o, por otro lado,
un libro donde las hojas no son
las de un árbol centralizador y
genealógico, sino precisamente
las de la muchedumbre,
que es la hierba como tal,
es decir, la hoja del rizoma,
en masiva sucesión
vertical continúa,
de repetidas e infinitas
verbosidades.
Como las de Whitman, la
hoja de mar de Quintero,
tampoco se quiere dejar
gobernar por el reino arbóreo,
que la pretende contener y colocarla
en el lugar correspondiente de su
destino jerárquico, menos que
ramo y mucho menos aún que tronco.
No, esta hoja declara su
directa relación con el mar,
que no importa cuán
lejana del literal,
acusa recibo de su deuda de agua,
porque es hacia una hoja que el agua
sube desde la tierra para evaporarse
y para dispersarse por el aire.
De hecho, una hoja usa solo el
5% del agua que recibe para su
fotosíntesis, el resto, se evapora.
La hoja está hecha,
pudiera decirse,
de y para el agua que recibe
de la lejanía del mar.
Ya desde el título, Quintero
propone que entre la hoja y el mar
hay un aire de familia, por lo
cual el literal no sería tanto un
límite, sino más bien un filtro,
una zona de traspaso para la
ingente transportación del agua por
todas partes.
La hoja de mar es un modo
metafórico de decir el
archipiélago y el libro que
sostenemos, de Juan Carlos Quintero,
quisiera ser esa hoja, quisiera
estar hecho de esa agua,
quisiera ser su efecto.
Un archipiélago, más que
ubicarse, sucede en el mar abierto,
en la altamar, lo suficientemente
alejado del fundamento continental,
como para que las condensaciones
telúricas que brotan de sus
entrañas no sean del todo distintas
de ese mismo mar abierto que,
por un lado, las rodea y las sitia,
pero que también las satura y
las convierte en espejismos vivos
del agua.
Esa sería la escena palpitante
de este libro de Quintero,
un libro de crítica poética,
donde el pensar adquiere el pulso
reiterativo y contundente de las
olas del mar.
Donde el pensar, como sugiere la
cita de Benjamín con que arranca el
libro, pertenece tanto al
movimiento como a la detención de
los pensamientos.
De ahí que la manera de enlazar el
título con el subtítulo de este
libro, no pueda ser sencillas dos
puntos, como suele ser el caso;
aquí, como si la metáfora
inicial sostuviese una relación de
condensación lírica al servicio
de su explicitación teórica,
que es la razón por la que
uno suele poner dos puntos,
que es quizás el modo más
común de titular un libro en la
academia norteamericana.
Con una metáfora condensatoria al
principio dos puntos y entonces,
de lo que se trata el libro,
del otro lado del puente
de los dos puntos.
Como suele ser el caso, como si la
metáfora inicial sostuviese una
relación de condensación lírica
al servicio de su explicitación
teórica, una metáfora para
sintetizar lo que el concepto
"efecto archipiélago"
se encargaría de
deshilvanar analíticamente.
Por ello, habría que poner los
dos puntos entre paréntesis,
como hace Juan Carlos, para des
familiarizar o poner en suspenso la
relación entre el
título y el subtítulo,
como si el paréntesis
fuese, de cierto modo,
una de esas muchas islas que
produce el efecto archipiélago,
una de sus posibles
hojas de agua; más aún,
como si el paréntesis fuese ya la
idea o la imagen misma en un efecto.
Pensar, como sugiere Benjamín,
no solo desde la detención
de los conceptos,
sino junto con el movimiento
de las metáforas,
que al mismo tiempo lo
presagian y lo abolen,
es uno de los deseos fervientes
de este libro y por ello,
hace alianza con singulares
portentos del pensamiento elíptico,
como Gilles Deleuze
y José Lezama Lima.
Un Deleuze, habría que añadir,
filtrado a través de su avatar
Caribe, Edward [inaudible].
Esa es una de las triadas
fundantes del libro,
Deleuze, [inaudible], Lizama.
Hay otras triadas.
Un libro de una modestia
intensamente afectada,
en íntimo diálogo con una
oscura poética de la relación,
dirigida a un cuerpo sin órganos
urdido mediante un sistema poético
del mundo.
Este libro es, entonces, más un
experimento que una interpretación,
un alevoso desorden de los sentidos.
La poesía es aquí la marca del
sentir que apalabra todo saber y el
sentido es primariamente eso,
afecto, la moción de la emoción,
el sentir de los sentidos o,
como se expresa elocuentemente en
"La máquina de la salsa", el sabor
del saber es el saber del sabor y la
salsa es eso, un saber
que sabe a goce.
Para que el sentido haga sentido,
Quintero plantea que sería
imprescindible no solo un intelecto,
sino sobre todo un sensorium,
una red de adherencias,
una diseminación de afectos.
Es ese el sensorium que organiza
este libro, siguiéndole la pista al
"Efecto Archipiélago", según hace
sus apariciones, a veces fugaces,
a veces contundentes en la red
que conecta insularismo con
"La isla que se repite", al tuntún
de pasa y grifería con la poética
de la relación, a la isla en
peso con [inaudible] y veinte,
al mar y tú con literal.
El sensorium desplaza la primacía
cronológica del índice temático y
la sustituye por la
elipsis del oleaje.
En este ensayo, los textos
discutidos regresan entre sí los
unos hacia los otros, no se
mueven por una fuerza resolutiva,
sino por un constante
devenir de un texto en otro.
El verbo con el que Quintero pone en
movimiento la relación con el mar
que produce el
"Efecto archipiélago" es el
verbo marear, el mar marea.
¿El mar marea, porque
refleja la marea?
Es decir, ¿el magnetismo
gravitacional que sobre él ejercen
el sol y la luna, por lo
cual el efecto archipiélago,
no es sino el rebote
de una fuerza sideral?
Lo que implica decir
que el mar descoloca,
que hecha por el suelo los cimientos
con los que se construye la
seguridad bípeda del Homo Sapiens.
Que incluso tira por la borda la
aparente seguridad del que piensa
que, para defenderse
del poderío del mar,
le basta con alejarse del literal.
De hecho, Quintero explora en sus
variadas travesías náuticas por
las páginas de [inaudible],
Benítez, Rojo, Rojo, Derek Walcott,
Palés [fonéticamente], Julia de
Burgos, Lezama o Virgilio Piñera,
entre otros, hasta qué
punto el efecto de mar,
que es en gran medida
el efecto archipiélago,
produce en el sujeto un
estado de dehiscencia,
de deposición de los imaginarios
constitutivos de la identidad.
El mar es cósmico, aún
más, es sideral y ubicuo.
Aún en la resaca,
cuando pareciera alejarse,
no hace sino humedecer la
tierra que posee con su rastro,
haciendo constancia de los
modos penetrantes de su estar en
todas partes.
Por eso es tan fundamental Quintero
despedazar en su libro la tan
supuesta oposición binaria
entre la isla y el mar, es decir,
dinamitar esa oposición
fragmentarla archipelágicamente y,
de paso, diluir del mismo modo la
relación que suele hacerse a partir
de esta oposición entre
el individuo y el otro.
Las lecturas que hace
de Lezama Lima,
en particular su célebre
coloquio con Juan Ramón Jiménez,
una de las obras primerizas
de Lezama,
en pérfida colaboración
dialógica,
el poeta de la generación del 27,
y la lectura extraordinaria que se
hace aquí de "La isla en peso",
de Virgilio Piñera, apuntan hacia
una suerte de geologización de la
geografía, donde la geología
se in distingue hidrología.
El mapa geográfico
se vuelve grieta,
piedra resquebrajada por
las humedades trópicas.
El ensayo es desde sus
comienzos ya con [inaudible],
de un modo muy particular,
un libro hecho de lecturas.
La potencia de un libro como este,
tan hecho y atravesado
por otros libros,
se debe en gran medida a su
pericia ensayística a la hora de
identificar sus referentes,
sus trozos citados, es
decir, sus lecturas.
Y Quintero posee una lujosa
capacidad para dar con hallazgos.
Uno de los más sorprendentes para
este lector es sin duda una cita que
extrae de una entrevista que le
hiciera Félix Guerra a José Lezama
Lima; y la pregunta que le
hace Guerra es la siguiente:
"¿Cómo ve el mar?".
Nótese que la pregunta no es qué
es el mar, sino cómo ve el mar.
Le pregunta Guerra a Lezama
y este contesta lo siguiente,
según la cita que hace
Quintero en el libro.
Dice Lezama: "El planeta es el ojo,
el mar es la pupila con la que
el ojo mira el universo y su
ampulosa eternidad.
El agua es el líquido acuoso
sentado sobre su cojinete de tejidos
conjuntivos, a cuál entra la
luz haciendo piruetas divertidas.
Miramos con el agua, aguzo el agua
y veo una eventual e inexplorada
soledad que se aleja y
alcanza, escribió [inaudible],
el récord del mundo en su altura.
Me inclino sobre mi balcón
existencial, es decir, el Malecón,
y ambos, él y yo, damos con
nuestros pechos a esa inmensidad
salada, donde intuimos peces
tridentes sargazos y náufragos de
diversas extirpes, todos en el coro,
con sus pulmones y
carrillos inflados,
porque cantan o la bullabesa o la
marsellesa o cualquier inspirado
himno del ahogado".
Fin de cita [risas].
Así es cómo Lezama le
contesta a un entrevistador.
[ Risas ]
>> Quintero, inspector sagaz de
las beaterías nacionalistas,
celebra el fino humor Lezamiano
ante la entonación submarina de los
himnos nacionales, en
boca de un ahogado.
Pero destaca a su vez un elemento
central de la escritura Lezamiana,
tan atravesada por su
condición asmática; el ahogado,
que canta desde las
profundidades del mar,
es el que respira debajo del agua,
el que triunfa y se sobrepone
a las cuitas del marear.
Estar mareado, se dice de un
aún más directo en inglés,
is to be seasick, es
ser presa del mar,
llevar el mar en los
pulmones, estar enfermo de mar.
El ahogado sería entonces
una figura central del efecto
archipiélago, es decir, el que sabe
respirar con los pulmones llenos
de agua.
Es poderoso, ese puente que conecta
la respiración acuosa del ahogado
con su mirada marina.
Su mirada no es otra calamidad
que la mirada del ojo,
que es ya el planeta todo,
como dice Lezama, ¿no?,
el planeta todo es un ojo enorme, un
ojo que mira con su pupila de mar.
Si el planeta es un ojo, el
mar es su pupila, es decir,
que el mar es de dónde se mira.
"¿Cómo dudar?
-estoy citando ahora a Quintero-
¿Cómo dudar -nos dice Quintero-
que quien contempla desde el
Malecón, también ha naufragado?".
Fin de cita.
Habría que añadir a su vez de
qué modo ese inmenso ojo del mundo,
con su pupila oceánica es
un trasunto del gongorino
cíclope Polifemo.
El efecto archipiélago, y esta es
su dimensión más contenciosa y,
por lo tanto, potenciadamente
significativa,
es una estatización
de la política,
que parte por un lado de la idea
de redistribución de lo sensible,
según la propone [inaudible], como
un disenso radical, una brecha,
hendidura o [inaudible] en el
sentido, un grito inarticulado,
que irrumpe en el interior del
lenguaje, meramente comunicativo,
para hacer ver la voz del otro.
Es decir que, desde el mar se mira
de otra manera y ese mirar es un
mirar sinestésico, que nos
hace escuchar la voz del otro.
Para que esto ocurra,
para que esto sea posible,
tendría que resquebrajarse la
ilusión de un sujeto autónomo,
individual, que parezca a sí mismo,
ajeno a su otredad circundante.
Porque es de esa otredad más
íntima de lo que todos sospechamos,
que proviene la singularidad que es
lo opuesto de la individualidad y de
la autonomía del sujeto.
Es con lo singular y lo apropiable
que Quintero relaciona su efecto
archipiélago, un efecto
desintegrador,
"una rajadura de sentido -uso
citando sus propias palabras-
donde una comunidad
caribeña se presenta."
Fin de cita.
Es un efecto, pero no porque sea
la consecuencia de una causa,
es un efecto sin causa,
que no procede de un origen común
que pueda trazarse a una creencia o
lengua o raza.
Es un efecto producido por la
insistencia de un diferimiento
constante, de un disenso
inapropiable,
que Quintero asemeja a una
corrosión subterránea,
marina que impide las
conexiones fáciles,
las cartografías recuperativas.
Es como si lo propio de lo marino
fuese la inminencia de la vibración
tectónica, el vislumbre
impostergable de un temblor,
un temblor cuyo efecto es la
inestabilidad de los géneros y de
las especies.
Por eso, en el español
puertorriqueño,
nos recuerda Quintero, mar se
dice tanto el mar como la mar,
como si en su interior se
disolviese la diferencia de género,
no solo ya del género sexual,
sino asimismo del género en su
sentido aristotélico, es decir,
como categoría organizativa
del conocimiento.
Juan Carlos Quintero Herencia se
abre paso entre la poesía y la
crítica joven del Caribe y de
Hispanoamérica o joven aún,
que se inscribe en
lo contemporáneo--
Un segundito, porque
si no tomo agua--
[ Risas y silencio ]
>> Si no tomo agua, no puedo mirar.
[ Risas ]
>> Juan Carlos Quintero Herencia
se abre paso entre la poesía y la
crítica joven del Caribe
y de Hispanoamérica,
que se inscribe en
lo contemporáneo,
según apunta a Gambell
[fonéticamente],
como el rumor del pasado
inconcluso en el presente o,
para decirlo desde el
barroco benjaminiano,
como el trabajo de la
ruina en el presente.
En Puerto Rico saltan a la vista
tres figuras para las cuales la
escritura se da en
un diálogo potente,
entre la poesía y la escritura;
José Luis Vega y Noel Luna son dos
ejemplos importantes de generaciones
distintas, quise decir
cuatro figuras.
La hora de Auria María Sotomayor
me parece un referente todavía más
cercano al proyecto de Quintero.
En ambos, no se trata solamente
de ser ensayistas y poetas,
sino de provocar infartos
verbales que develen,
que saquen a la luz la sobrevivencia
de la poesía en el ensayo,
así como la potencialidad
de un saber de la poesía.
Desde ese punto de vista, la hoja
de mar de Quintero es un libro tan
singular como el estupendo
"Femina Faber" de Sotomayor.
Del mismo modo, la hoja de mar es un
libro que, desde el ensayo crítico,
puede leerse como una reverberación
crítica de los dos últimos libros
de poesía de Quintero,
"El libro del sigiloso" y
"El cuerpo del milagro".
Desde poéticas muy distintas
podría hablarse a su vez de
experimentos similares en el
ensayismo del cubano Antonio José
Ponte y del argentino Daniel Lind.
Finalmente, si fuésemos a intentar
un modo de amarrar el lazo elíptico
de ese neobarroco quinteriano,
tendríamos que recurrir
a él mismo.
Los dejo con esta cita de Hoja de
mar: "Esa palabra trabada [vacío],
esa figura interpuesta tal
vez sumergida o en flotación,
entre perspectivas, es la escritura
múltiple del desacuerdo mismo que
habilita la política literaria".
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Muchas gracias, Rubén.
Solamente Rubén puede hacer
semejante exégesis poética con la
elegancia con la que lo ha hecho.
Así que Juan, lo vas
a tener duro ahora.
Le doy la palabra a Juan Duchesne.
>> Bien, quiero agradecer al
departamento de español y
portugués de Maryland [inaudible].
Y las personas de aquí de
la Biblioteca del Congreso,
de la Sala Hispánica,
quiero agradecer la invitación y
la organización de este evento.
Bien, yo le tengo un título a esta
presentación del libro de Juan
Carlos Quintero, le he llamado
"El telurismo materialista de
Juan Carlos Quintero Herencia,
hoja de mar, efecto archipiélago".
Y le tengo también un epígrafe,
tomado de la novela de Enrique
Bernardo Núñez, "Cubagua",
que dice: "El mar es comunista".
[ Risas ]
>> Creo que conviene trastocar el
sentido de la palabra auténtico.
Lo auténtico convencional es lo
aprobado y certificado por una
autoridad acreditadora, pero existen
cosas que nos parecen auténticas
precisamente porque
ocurren fuera de programa,
fuera de la cuantificación
y del cálculo.
Estamos aquí ante
un libro académico,
pero intelectualmente auténtico,
publicado por una editorial
extranjera,
en una lengua minoritaria, que
es un verdadero ensayo y no un
paper ampliado.
Hoja de Mar (: ) Efecto
Archipiélago I de Juan Carlos
Quintero Herencia, se suma a la
tradición latinoamericana del
ensayo de interpretación del
carácter de una nación región o
sub región, tradición que en
muchos casos sacude no solo a la
historia y la sociología,
sino a la geo poética.
La geo poética es lo que antes
llamaban influencia del paisaje o
determinismo geográfico, pero que
realmente va más allá del paisaje
y del determinismo.
Dicha tradición es más amplia y
diversa de lo que sugieren títulos
como "Facundo" de Domingo
Francino Sarmiento,
"Un hombre que está solo y
espera" de Raúl Scalabrini Ortiz,
"Radiografía de la pampa" de
Ezequiel Martínez Estrada,
"Raza de bronce" de
Alcides Arguedas,
"El laberinto de la
soledad", de Octavio Paz,
"El laberinto de los tres
Minotauros" de Juan Manuel Briceño
Guerrero, "Casa grande y
censada" de Gilberto Freire,
"Insularismo" de Antonio
S. Pedreira, "Guatemala,
las líneas de su mano"
de Luis Cardoza y Aragón,
"La expresión americana"
de José Lezama Lima,
"Indagación del choteo" de Jorge
Mañach, "El pez de oro" de Churata,
"El puertorriqueño
dócil" de René Marqués,
"El arte de bregar" de
Arcadio Díaz Quiñones,
""La isla que se repite""
de Antonio Benítez Rojo y,
últimamente, "Donde"
de Eduardo Lalo.
Hay muchos aciertos y también
muchos despropósitos en ese tipo de
experimento, pero creo que el
procedimiento mismo de trabajar a
partir de una o más
figuras históricas,
sociológicas o poéticas,
para caracterizar un espacio
social y geo poético,
sigue siendo viable y acertado,
en especial cuando se
acude a la geo poética;
pues pensar desde el cuerpo y su
lugar en el mundo es ineludible,
pese a que se pueda discutir en
qué medida dichos ensayos de este
género logran hacerlo
y con qué resultados.
La pretensión de acceder a un
pensamiento absolutamente desligado
del cuerpo y del espacio
que articula el cuerpo,
cuál si se pudiera pensar
abstracciones flotantes en el
universo, se estrella contra la
negación de sus propias condiciones
de posibilidad.
Hay descorporizaciones y hay
desterritorializaciones cierto,
pero siempre suponen el devenir
otro cuerpo y otro territorio,
como quiera que se mire.
¿Qué es el efecto archipiélago?
Es una constelación de metáforas,
conceptos y referencias de
inspiración ampliamente telúrica.
La introducción de hoja de
mar es un manifiesto en fuga,
donde sucesivas aproximaciones
al efecto archipiélago,
son capaces de abarcar más de
500, perdón, 50 páginas [risas].
Cada intento de definición
efectivamente huye de la
definición categórica.
Como cuestión de principios,
este ensayo pospone la claridad del
concepto a favor de la exactitud de
la expresión.
No se puede, perdón, no se pretende
tanto de explicar cómo si de
expresar el pensamiento a
través de los cinco, seis,
nueve u once sentidos
sensoriales y sus combinaciones.
Este ensayo no discursea sobre la
importancia de la estética en la
interpretación, es más bien
una expresión estética del acto
de interpretar.
Por ahí hay quién habla
de prosa poética, ¿no?,
como si hablara de un
realce al maquillaje,
pero más bien aquí tenemos la
voluntad de estilo inseparable de la
voluntad de pensar.
Ahora bien, ¿qué es, en
fin, el efecto archipiélago?
Lo mejor es citar una de las
incontables definiciones esbozadas
en el texto.
Y dice el texto de Juan Carlos:
"El efecto archipiélago
es un efecto sin causa,
pues la aventura marina
es hundimiento y pérdida,
condición sin pivote, llamado
de la carne de la marejada -
estás compitiendo aquí con Lezama-
bajo el árbol playero en la noche,
el archipiélago acentúa la
penumbra que alebresta a los
animales nocturnos.
Marea, marejada, mareamientos
por ausencia de luz,
estética de las mareas, son
algunos de sus disfraces,
pues allí se consigna que esta
teoría del mareo no es una
disfuncionalidad simple,
sino la marca de un orden sensorial
tan expuesto a sus aguas como las
formas de la confusión, donde se
tornan indistinguibles el agua del
rectángulo, la baba o el caracol".
La abundancia de estas secuencias
líricas no bloquea el concepto,
sino que lo transporta,
lo desplaza, lo voltea,
lo acompaña incluso
en sus contradicciones.
Hay una contradicción, por ejemplo,
según lo leo yo y no es el cometido
de estas líneas denunciarla ni
reclamar que se resuelva;
por un lado,
se sostiene que el efecto
archipiélago es pura imagen,
en el sentido de la
figura poética, textual,
invocándose aquí aquel
famoso interdicto del género
lingüístico en la crítica, de
que no hay nada fuera del texto;
pero, por otro lado, se plantea
con la mayor insistencia,
que el efecto archipiélago
antecede al lenguaje y al texto.
Cito: "En el archipiélago,
lo primero es el cuerpo".
Las islas, las playas,
las mareas, los moluscos,
crustáceos y agua vivas, las fallas
geológicas, las placas tectónicas,
las montañas, las fosas, las
hendiduras, las rajaduras,
los orificios, las
secreciones, las extremidades,
la potencia e impotencia del deseo,
entrelazan el cuerpo
y el territorio,
como factores geo poéticos
del efecto archipiélago.
El efecto archipiélago también
invoca a una comunidad que se
adjetiva como democrática,
más bien a manera de una
interrogante indefinible o definida
negativamente como exceso político
ante puesto al comunitarismo de
etnia y nación.
Y al concepto del "Pueblo",
entre comillas.
Se invoca a la política,
pero entendida como disenso,
corrosivamente impolítico,
en consonancia con las
ideas ampliamente citadas de
Jack Ranciere.
Por otro lado, mediante incisivas
reconsideraciones de [inaudible] se
cuestiona la manera
en que este pensador--
[inaudible] convierte el legado
revolucionario de Haití y de Cuba,
en eje histórico del Caribe.
Si algo, el efecto archipiélago
no pretende ser revolucionario,
como tampoco claro,
contrarrevolucionario.
Y cito: "Lo archipiélago no
salva ni reivindica, ni redime.
Dejémosle estos asuntos a los
curas, a los pastores, profesores,
poetas o escritores con
sotanas invisibles".
Fin de la cita.
El efecto archipiélago tampoco
reivindica expresiones marginales
ni oprimidas.
Tampoco reivindica la identidad
basada en la lengua ni en la, cito:
"Co participación sanguínea
o pigmentográfica ni -
cito- en los fetiches de la
heterogeneidad [inaudible]".
Estos [inaudible] se proclaman a
veces con la resolución tajante
del manifiesto.
El efecto archipiélago se
define, en gran medida como ven,
por la vía negativa, parece que
la suma de cosas que el efecto
archipiélago no es, ayuda
más a caracterizarlo,
que el destilado casi imposible
de lo que efectivamente pueda ser;
sin embargo, de tal destilado se
desprende algo muy interesante que
el archipiélago sí podría ser,
y que podría caracterizar una
propuesta central del ensayo,
un cuerpo telúrico o más bien una
constelación de cuerpos telúricos.
El cuerpo telúrico es legión
como el demonio, es decir,
se trata más bien de un enjambre
multiespecie de cuerpos humanos,
animales, vegetales, geológicos,
climáticos, poéticos,
conceptuales, sensoriales,
afectivos y tecnológicos,
al que [inaudible] imputa una fuerte
orientación terráquea que no
necesariamente apunta
para trascender,
imputa una fuerte orientación
terráquea que no apunta a la
trascendencia ni a la inmanencia,
sino a un sin fin de
maneras de bregar.
Yo traduje su expresión
[inaudible] que--
stain with a trouble, como bregar.
Bajo la expresión cuerpo telúrico,
bajo la expresión cuerpo telúrico
en las ideas de [inaudible],
aunque ella no emplea dicha frase.
El adjetivo telúrico tiene
mala prensa en la crítica
latinoamericana, en especial desde
que Carlos Fuentes y otros voceros
del boom literario
latinoamericano del siglo pasado,
volcaran su desprecio contra la
llamada novela de la tierra y sus
invocaciones telúricas.
Desconcierta mucho, de hecho,
la manera en que aquel telurismo
pretendía fundir la tierra a los
proyectos hegemónicos
de la nación criolla.
Pero estamos en otra época,
y el tema de la tierra
se ve de otra manera,
ante el impacto del Antropoceno.
Propongo trastocar aquel sentido
común de la palabra telúrico por
un sentido mutante, desde tal
sentido es que me permito señalar
que Juan Carlos Quintero realiza en
su ensayo nada menos que una lectura
telúrica de importantes autores
del Caribe insular hispanófono.
Aunque el ensayo de Quintero
lleva sus referencias a Rancie a ,
veremos que si, según
dice Ranciere,
la política comienza cuando se
expresa en la sociedad un elemento
que antes no contaba para nada
que antes no tenía voz en ella,
entonces la irrupción
de la disímil y común,
e incomún comunidad
telúrica apunta aquí,
a una política radicalmente otra,
que no se limita a la especie Homo
Sapiens ni culmina en ella y que
tampoco se limita a
relaciones entre especies,
sino también entre sus
partes y sus órganos.
Tal vez, sin proponérselo así,
el efecto archipiélago convoca a
una legión de actores políticos
nunca reconocidos por
las polis modernas.
Esa legión de demonios políticos
es un cuerpo hecho de muchos cuerpos
heterogéneos, humanos y no
humanos, bióticos y abióticos,
con órganos, sin órganos
y con trasplantes.
El efecto archipiélago con sus
redes y enjambres de mareas,
moluscos, crustáceos,
vientos, lluvias, rayos, playas,
fallas geológicas, hendiduras,
rajas, orificios, bocas, deseos,
sabores, olores, imágenes,
toqueteos, vaginas, penes,
estómagos, ojos, secreciones,
aparatos y artificios poéticos,
afirma pese a sus negaciones,
una suerte de cuerpo telúrico
inseparable de cierta poética,
según sugiere el propio texto en
varias proposiciones como esta;
por ejemplo, cito: "La abertura
archipielágica vincula al cuerpo
con lo perceptible, como
extensión y como saber acuático".
Numerosos pasajes del libro matizan
las expresiones articuladas al
cuerpo saber terrestre, del
saber animal, del saber vegetal,
etc. Y cito, bastante, una cita que
me gusta mucho: "Más que un saber,
lo sensorial es una disposición
significante del cuerpo y sus
sentidos hacia aquello que
lo rebasa y se abre ante sí.
La incorporación de los sentidos
será siempre luego asunto de
interpretaciones, de
absorciones, de [inaudible],
de zamarreos, de [inaudible].
Ya sea como confusión del final de
la tierra y el comienzo inabarcable
del mar, la ola es un
paréntesis giratorio de agua o,
como confusión del [inaudible]
y el objeto de sus sentidos,
la falla archipielágica
alabanza las sensaciones en un
transitar negativo.
El ojo es una hendidura saturada,
lubricada entre los párpados.
La lengua, por eso hablo
de órganos también,
habita la hendidura de la boca y
allí dispone de la saliva o el aire
pronunciable de las palabras.
En condición de archipiélago, las
hendiduras agitan las porosidades.
La hendidura remolino, la hendidura
resaca, la hendidura [inaudible],
la hendidura coral, la hendidura
esponja, la hendidura sexo,
la hendidura sedimento, la hendidura
arena están hechas para meditar,
para estar entre los cuerpos y
las imágenes de los sentidos".
Leo todo esto, porque quiero
seguir enfatizando el telurismo.
Según Elizabeth [inaudible] los
cuerpos son entes transformadores
por definición y todo cuerpo
es [inaudible], es decir,
que posee un eros esquizo e
histérico al existir como cuerpo
solo en el acto mismo de
establecer relaciones de devenir,
otro con otros cuerpos, con
órganos de otros cuerpos,
con partículas de
esos otros cuerpos,
mediante devoraciones
digestivas y reproductivas.
Ello implica que todo
cuerpo es parcial,
incompleto y fragmentario
por definición.
Todo cuerpo es una serie
de metamorfosis en cursos,
las hendiduras [inaudible]
tectónicas y orgánicas evocan el
trasplante continuo de
órganos según las [inaudible].
Es el caso del cuerpo
telúrico del archipiélago,
al cual Juan Carlos Quintero
Herencia acude para realizar una
serie de trasplantes en las
letras hispano antillanas,
que redundan en un archipiélago que
se repite y que es importante que se
repita, pues aquí la
repetición es creativa,
es contra efectuación
continua del presente.
Nada más indicado que iniciar esa
serie archipielágica como lo hace
el libro, con "La isla que
se repite" de Benítez Rojo.
A partir de una operación crítica
sobre "La isla que se repite",
Quintero dirime de manera muy
sugerente y pedagógica la querella
de los insulares y
los continentales,
para proponer un archipiélago
que se repita más allá de la
dicotomía isla continente.
Como es de esperarse, la metáfora
archipiélago resulta más
abarcadora que la metáfora isla.
Quintero demuestra a saciedad que,
en comparación con
el archipiélago,
la isla de Benítez Rojo se queda
corta en aquello de repetirse,
que no es sino una manera de
diseminar la diferencia prolífica
del Caribe.
Debo remarcar que este
abordaje archipielágico de
"La isla que se repite",
oscila entre las aperturas para
multiplicidad y las restricciones
del giro lingüístico.
Es que yo tengo una peleíta con
el giro lingüístico, entonces,
la estoy metiendo aquí,
a ver si funciona.
[ Risas ]
>> Por aquello de que, para
muestra un botón, basta,
me detengo brevemente en esta
instancia de oscilación que
involucra diferentes temas
a lo largo del libro.
El giro lingüístico
acarrea, como es de suponer,
cierto positivismo universalista,
en la medida en que dé recurso a la
hegemonía de la lengua y, de paso,
la letra alfabética excluye formas
de conocimiento y de existencia que
no pasan por esos códigos
glotocéntricos, o sea,
glotocéntrico basado en un lenguaje
humano, hablado, verbal, ¿no?
Ello sucede hasta en
las mejores familias.
Es la situación de Levi
Strauss, el gran antropólogo,
en sus célebres mitológicas,
las que despliegan un reconocimiento
realmente impresionante de la
materialidad que enhebra
el pensamiento mitológico,
pero suprime esa materialidad cuando
la disuelve en el juego abstracto de
las oposiciones estructurales
de la lengua,
con tal de autentificar y acreditar
la posibilidad universalista de
la investigación.
Cuando aborda el ensayo "La isla
que se repite" de Benítez Rojo,
Quintero Herencia plantea
convincentemente que,
para Benítez Rojo, la naturaleza
del Caribe aparece, ¿no?,
como dispensadora privilegiada
de una armonía y [inaudible] que
prevalece igualmente a histórico,
sobre los desafueros de la historia
traída supuestamente por Europa y
concluye que el autor
cubano soslaya así,
con tradiciones importantes
de la vida de la región.
Esto suena bien y coincido.
No coincido sin embargo con la
estrategia analítica seguida en
este punto por Quintero Herencia,
de concentrar la crítica del ensayo
cubano sobre el hecho de que en este
se recurra a la magia
ancestral y su autor parezca,
como dicen en Puerto Rico, su autor
parezca en creer en cosas de esas,
¿no?
De agüeros y revelaciones.
Me parece que impugnar el
recurso a la magia en sí misma,
como insuficiencia de la crítica
es cargar un fardo ilustrado y
positivista, de hecho, bastante
sujeto a la dicotomía cristiana
occidental, de la creencia
y la incredulidad.
La pertenencia de saberes
ancestrales como el animismo y la
magia, no tiene nada que
ver con creer o no creer,
sino con los conceptos y
herramientas propuestos para el
pensamiento y con procedimientos
de acción convenientes
o inconvenientes.
La magia y la consecuente
revelación de la cierta manera de
caminar de las mujeres
negras cubanas,
constituye más que nada una
constatación del encantamiento del
objeto real, del efecto
que [inaudible] llama en
inglés [inaudible].
Ese artificio imaginativo del acto
estético que tantea [inaudible] del
objeto real, en este caso la
atmósfera afectiva que acompañó
la crisis de octubre
de 1962 en Cuba.
Esa es la dimensión del
encantamiento de [inaudible] del
caminar de la negra cubana, al
cual se refiere Benítez Rojo,
al cual Benítez Rojo atribuye
una revelación mágica,
por su capacidad de desmentir la
atmósfera apocalíptica dominante.
Yo acotaría que, en
lugar de la magia en sí,
sin la cual no hay arte
ni literatura que valga,
lo fallido en la centralidad e
importancia desproporcionada que
adquieren las metáforas geo
poéticas de la isla y la
plantación, en el
ensayo de Benítez Rojo,
algo que también se menciona
en el ensayo, se apunta.
O sea, queda claro también.
La condena implícita y explícita
reiterada [inaudible] de todo lo que
sea telurismo, saberes
ancestrales, tradiciones o magia,
corre a lo largo de todo el libro,
acompañada de invocaciones
de las mareas, las arenas,
los movimientos tectónicos,
los fenómenos meteorológicos,
la fisiología corporal, los
sentidos, las percepciones,
los afectos y los encuentros
multiespecies y multiórganos.
Invocaciones que, de hecho, al
conceder agencia a la materialidad,
al animar como lo hace, ¿no?,
[inaudible] de entes materiales,
redundan en un procedimiento
de encantamiento mágico de los
textos abordados.
O sea, aquí uno está leyendo,
como vimos en las citas
y todo, la magia, ¿no?
Si algo fascina en la escritura
de Juan Carlos Quintero,
y aquí incluyo su poesía es
su mágica relación con una
corporalidad multiespecie
diseminada.
Igual sucede con los autores
caribeños que enfoca,
bueno, no todos.
Por ejemplo, la metáfora del
ajiaco de Fernando Ortiz es un
impresionante encuentro telúrico
de multiespecies vegetales,
animales y minerales,
en un caldo [inaudible],
animador de una transculturación;
pero Quintero lo ostenta como
un expediente anti telúrico
por excelencia.
Tal pareciera que para Quintero
todo lo que resuma magia,
tradición ancestral,
sentido de la tierra,
saberes no filtrados
por [inaudible],
podría ser equivalente a un
residuo pre moderno y, por esa vía,
vinculado a una metafísica
originaria que alimentaria,
que de hecho esa metafísica existe,
pero que alimentaria al populismo,
al nacionalismo y el totalitarismo,
presuntamente ejemplificados por el
nacionalismo puertorriqueño y la
revolución cubana
y casos semejantes.
De ahí que un gesto no tan
diferente del ejemplo ya citado de
Levi Strauss, Quintero
recurra a, de alguna manera,
prevenir o proteger su indudable
vocación telúrica y mágica
depurándola mediante la [inaudible]
del giro lingüístico de todo
elemento anti moderno.
Por suerte, ese gesto
contradictorio, en cierta manera,
realza lo que pretende eludir.
Es un acto de prestidigitación
en reversa,
en lugar de hacer pasar
el [inaudible] por magia,
pretende escamotear la magia y
pasarla por método positivo,
a la manera del mago de la
novela homónima que se llamaba
"El mago" de César
Águila, que se contrariaba,
"El mago" de César Águila se
contrariaba porque los trucos le
salían como magia de verdad.
Era un mago que estaba frustrado,
porque hacía magia de verdad
y no eran trucos, entonces,
no podía demostrar
ni la clase de magia.
[ Risas ]
>> Yo creo que hay algo de esto.
Ese impulso contrario,
como la fricción del aire que
opone y levanta el ala del pájaro,
de alguna manera realza el vuelo
mágico de la prosa de Quintero,
cual si esta quisiera
lucir su perseverancia.
Por tanto, la buena noticia
es, y estoy convencido de ello,
que hoja de mar en su exégesis
contra corriente de siete autores
del canon cubano puertorriqueño,
constituye el evento más importante
de la crítica caribeñista de los
últimos años.
Ahí-- Tiene razón--
Rubén en mencionar
"Femina Faber" que va
por ese camino ya, ¿no?
Pero ya en el archipiélago se
completa, ¿no?, como con todo.
Juan Carlos Quintero logra volarse
y escapar del performance de la
identidad, esto es lo importante,
aparte de mi peleíta con la
parte lingüística, en verdad,
la política cultural,
esto es lo importante,
logra volarse y escapar del
performance de la identidad y las
tres rutinas de la etnia,
género y nación, que son tres,
que como él señala, constituyen
el repertorio multiculturalista
impuesto al investigador
académico actual, ¿no?
Eso se impone, eso si uno no hace,
lo puede pasar mal,
tú lo explicas ahí.
Quienes buscamos algo más que
ese repertorio multiculturalista,
ya disponemos de una pletórica
pormenorizada y reveladora relectura
que nos lleva a recorrer para mal o
para bien la brujería de Benítez
Rojo, que sí es medio
brujo, la hermenáutica,
que no la hermenéutica del capitán
metafórico Antonio Pereira.
Eso es lo mejor que
pudiste hacer por Pereira,
llamarlo capitán metafórico,
no sé si te lo van
agradecer los periodistas,
pero lo deber es agradecer.
La gastronomía de Fernando Ortiz,
la anemografía de
José Lezama Lima,
la oceanografía de Julio
de Burgos, y esto lo digo,
no es que yo quiera usar palabras,
esas son palabras del libro, ¿no?,
del texto del propio Juan Carlos y
entra en detalles para convencernos
de eso.
Y lo mejor de todo, la
gastroenterología óptica,
trasplante de estómago con ojo
de Pales Matos y, finalmente,
la carnicería de Virgilio Piñera,
porque eso es una carnicería,
lo que ocurrió ahí,
más allá del trasplante.
Pasamos del multiculturalismo a lo
que Eduardo Riveros de Castro llama,
y creo que esto es una
muestra, el multinatural,
donde la naturaleza deja de
ser el premio inmaculado,
como a veces de cierta manera lo
usa Benítez Rojo, no siempre,
pero en muchos casos, contra
puesto a la cultura y obligado a
fundamentarla, ¿no?, para diseminar
la multiplicidad y el artificio,
el conflicto y la complicidad
en heterogéneas poblaciones
multiespecies; es decir,
que la naturaleza,
en lugar de fundamentar la unicidad,
la identidad de la cultura,
lo que hace es que la disemina,
la hace estallar, ¿no?
Eso es lo que hace
aquí Juan Carlos,
básicamente, eso es lo que hace.
Entonces, por ahí--
Bueno, eso es, ya terminé.
Muchas gracias por escucharme.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Bueno, gracias, Juan, por
básicamente, situar este libro,
¿no?, en una genealogía
confrontacional con grandes textos
latinoamericanos y del Caribe
y dejarnos saber, exactamente,
qué es lo que secreta o derrama o
el hechizo que nos manda este libro,
¿no?
Voy a ser rebelde un momentito,
voy a dar las gracias
ahora a mitad de esto,
porque no lo hice al principio,
para que las escuchen bien, no,
sobre todo Georgette Dorn,
la directora de aquí de la
división hispánica y a Thalía
Guzmán que ha sido nuestra
cómplice en una serie de
actividades que hemos planeado
en la Biblioteca del Congreso.
Gracias por esta colaboración y
al departamento de español de la
Universidad de Maryland,
siempre está dispuesto
a hacerlo con ustedes.
Y gracias a ustedes por estar aquí,
sobre todo gracias
a Rubén y a Juan,
que se brindaron para hacer este
banquete que nos acaban de dar.
Y espero que Juan Carlos haya tenido
unos cuantos minutos para pensarse
lo que tiene que decir ahora,
porque lo que voy a hacer es pedirle
que responda a lo que han dicho
Rubén y Juan y que,
de cierta manera,
si se parece que hay algo que
falta o que irías en contra de
[inaudible] y lo que esperamos
es armar un diálogo aquí,
en el que ustedes también
puedan participar.
>> ¿Se me escucha?
¿Se me escucha?
Bueno, yo-- Yo no voy a
añadir más, en verdad,
porque ya creo que ellos han tenido
que soportar esas 400 páginas y--
Lo único que puedo es volver a
darle las gracias a Georgette y a
Thalía, a mis colegas, ¿no?
El departamento, a los
estudiantes graduados,
iba a decir míos también.
En realidad, celebrar el lujo que
supone tener estos lectores, ¿no?
Ya lo que ellos han dicho y hecho
es materia de conversación futura,
¿no?
Yo me siento honrado por la escucha
de ellos y, de alguna manera,
estos libros son posibles porque hay
una serie de conversaciones y de,
y de intercambios anteriores
a ellos, ¿no?
Ellos yo sé que no les gusta que
yo les diga esto, pero son maestros,
para mí han sido maestros
en más de un sentido,
ahora afortunadamente, son amigos
y quieren que así los trate.
De alguna manera, uno escribe para
estar a la altura de estas lecturas,
¿no?
Entonces, yo preferiría, ya lo
que yo tenía que decir sobre el
archipiélago está ahí.
Yo preferiría escuchar preguntas
o comentarios y, otra vez,
darles las gracias
por esta oportunidad.
>> Se está escapando, ¿no?
>> Sí, por la hendidura.
[ Risas ]
>> Una pregunta.
[ Inaudible ]
>> ¿Me estás preguntando a mí?
>> Sí.
>> Bueno, una de las ficciones
analíticas del libro,
yo creo que yo aprendí con mi
maestro Ricardo [inaudible] a
construir ficciones interpretativas,
creo que es cómo él las llamaba--
Digamos, yo doy por
cierto o el mago cree,
que el trabajo del agua es
constante sobre la tierra,
que este problema de la--
Esta batalla, este antagonismo muy
binario de isla y agua, continente,
isla, lo que reproduce o
proyecta es una serie quizás de--
De auto figuraciones de los
proyectos de los respectivos autores
de enfrentar esto.
Yo creo que a mí me interesó
pensar esos textos desde el agua.
Yo creo que en realidad lo que
tienen en común muchos de--
Tanto el paisaje digestivo
de Pales Matos,
la maldita circunstancia del
agua por todas partes de Virgilio
Piñera, yo quiero subrayar
que es por todas partes,
no la circunferencia.
E inclusive en el caso de Pedreira,
un poco el atrevimiento o el
hallazgo mío en el libro es que
hay, más allá de la figuración,
Pedreira imagina el
mar como un cinturón,
creo que es la única figuración
que yo he encontrado de imaginar el
mar, literalmente, como una
correa que aprieta la cintura.
Es algo muy singular.
A mí me ha interesado también,
creo que son todas poéticas que,
de alguna manera, testimonian la
saturación de la tierra por el
agua, y que el mar en realidad
está por todas partes, ¿no?
Y que hay algo indeciso,
indeterminado.
El hallazgo de la cita que Rubén
leyó, ¿no?, es muy interesante,
porque ese libro en particular,
Félix Guerra era un
periodista y crítico cubano,
acabado de salir una famosa
compilación de entrevistas
que hizo.
>> Valoración múltiple.
Él ya se había acercado a Lezama
en Cuba, en Casa de las Américas,
se había acercado a Lezama con un
proyecto de entrevistas y cuando
salió la Valoración
Múltiple de Lezama,
descubrió que se había
quedado sin proyecto.
Entonces, se acerca
a Lezama y le dice,
pues vamos a hablar de cualquier
cosa que no sea literatura,
que no sea cultura, que no sea
arte, pero ya ustedes oyen cómo--
Lezama es una coherencia
barroca y elíptica que,
así contesta también
qué prefiere,
si un libro o un asado de cordero,
es como que no puede
manejar otro registro, ¿no?
Entonces, esta idea de la
ubicuidad del agua es continua.
Pales, también Pales es un poeta
muy singular que es el único que
tiene una teoría digestiva
del paisaje.
Epe [fonéticamente] aquí este
paisaje digestivo dice en su
célebre poema Menú, el Caribe es
en realidad un paisaje digestivo,
entonces con qué órgano
uno lo percibe.
Entonces, de alguna manera,
colocarme frente a estas poéticas y
estos textos fue también enfrentar
los retos que suponían, ¿no?
Y también volver a ellos,
porque creo que estaban ausentes
en las grandes teorías, ¿no?,
de lo caribeño o de lo insular.
Entonces, yo estoy idealmente,
quisiera estar en el agua,
pero creo que el agua siempre
está, ¿no?, siempre está ahí.
[ Silencio ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Están tímidos.
>> Es la corrosión
del salitre, ¿no?
También una de las maneras de ver
ese relevo de materialidad de lo
acuático, es verlo también
en el viento salitroso, ¿no?
Pero también hay otra
metáfora si tú quieres,
otra corporalidad operando bajo la
idea del mar, además del mareo,
que es la del marinado, también
las corrosiones son constitutivas de
procesos culinarios,
de procesos gástricos,
de procesos gastronómicos.
Es necesario también para
absorber, descomponer.
Entonces, a mí me
interesó un poco dejarme--
Es algo que creo que vengo
haciendo con mis libros,
que es como dejarme afectar y
contaminar por los objetos que leo.
No la idea de colocarme fuera de
ellos y domesticarlos o enmarcarlos,
como se dice.
Se me hace muy difícil,
por muchas razones,
tanto éticas como políticas.
Entonces, era también lidiar con la
corrosión también, es una manera,
algo que hablábamos ayer
con, hablaba con Juan,
también lidiar con nuestra
finitud, con una mortalidad.
También muchas de estas teorías
y reflexiones parecen que son
enunciados que vivirán por siempre
o que están hablando de situaciones
que no van a tener
declinación final, ¿no?
Entonces, por ahí va también la
reflexión con lo negativo, ¿no?
Creo que aceptar esta suerte de
mortalidad o finitud de ciertos
procesos y objetos, es también
una manera muy saludable de pasar y
dejar que vengan otros y
digan y hagan otra cosa.
[ Silencio ]
>> Tengo una preguntita
para Juan Carlos.
>> ¡Ay! Jesús.
[ Risas ]
>> Era una especie como de
presentimiento que experimenté
durante la lectura del libro y el
final del ensayo de Juan y me lo
avivó, cuando uno lee tu libro,
encontraste con "La
máquina de la salsa",
un libro que a mí me encanta, yo
sentía "La máquina de la salsa",
un goce extraordinario por
un lado, pero por otro lado,
un espíritu rencilloso, ¿no?,
casi podría decir una rabia que a
veces hasta amenazaba con destruir
la contentura, porque estabas en pie
de guerra contra todos los que para
ti redujeron la salsa,
la disciplinaron para convertirla
en una especie de itinerario de
deberes, ¿no?
Los deberes antropológicos,
pedagógicos, políticos,
académicos.
Y eso era como una
especie de [inaudible];
nunca estuve en desacuerdo contigo,
pero sí me molestaba que me
destruyeras el placer de la lectura
porque, cuando por otro
lado bailabas con la prosa,
y la erudición tuya salsística
nunca deja de conmoverme.
Y noto una paz, por un
lado, en este libro,
quizás la palabra sea sosiego--
No es que el libro deje de
ser muy duro con lo mismo,
pero ya es una cosa tan asumida,
que como que sentí que
ya no era necesario--
Me lo disfruté muchísimo.
Pero irónicamente, por otro lado,
leía y esta es la
pregunta que te hago,
cierto desencanto con
la creencia, ¿no?
Una especie de--
>> ¿Con qué?
>> Con la creencia.
>> Con la creencia, que es
lo que tú llamas magia,
el pensamiento mágico, toda
esa crítica que tú haces,
pero que al final salvas, porque un
poco como que la vuelves al revés
en tu, en tu ensayo-- Y nada,
te quería preguntar si se podía
hablar de tal cosa como una
revelación del descreer,
una absoluta contradicción.
Yo no sé, yo no dejaba de sentir
eso también y que, por otro parte,
con toda la rabia de
la magia de la salsa,
yo siempre lo sentí como un
libro profundamente espiritual.
Que hay una conexión entre
la salsa, por un lado,
el baile por otro, el
goce es sagrado, ¿no?
>> El agua.
>> ¿Perdón?
>> Y el agua.
>> Y al agua.
¿Qué piensas?
¿Es un disparate que
me estoy inventando?
[ Risas ]
>> El problema de ser
leído por estos señores,
es que uno está al
desnudo, descubierto, ¿no?
Porque sí, el libro de la salsa,
es un libro que yo decido escribir
profundamente perturbado y molesto
por lo que yo empezaba
a leer como, ¿verdad?,
estudios o reflexiones
sobre los salseros,
en academias tanto norteamericanas
como latinoamericanas.
Y esto es una larga
conversación que yo he tenido,
sobre todo que he tenido con Ivette
sobre esta suerte de que muchas
veces, hasta este libro,
para escribir necesito escribir
a veces en contra, ¿no?
Hay mucho de enfrentamiento hacia
ciertos modos de leer, ¿cierto?
A veces ciertas ritualidades y,
ciertas genuflexiones,
ciertas domesticaciones.
Y yo creo que, leyéndome o leyendo
a mis lectores y a los que me
criticaban, me decían
esto de otra manera, ¿No?
Y es algo que yo traté
deliberadamente de mantener a raya
en este libro, ¿no?, porque
quizás, y yo lo digo al principio,
quizás en esas batallas, se
estaba poniendo en evidencia,
quizás algo que tiene que ver
conmigo más que con lo que estaba
pasando con los textos.
Era una manera mía de entrar yo en
el escenario, autorizarme, ¿no?,
y era una forma de, en realidad,
muy-- Podemos decir más masculina,
de invitar a pelear a
alguien, macharrana,
para decidir, para
decidir el asunto.
Pero también, bajo ese gesto,
iba también un esfuerzo--
Yo no diría deliberado, pero sí
muy preocupado éticamente por
lidiar, o sea, por batallar con
situaciones que ameritaban una
palabra y un diferendo.
Me perturbaba mucho eso, ¿no?
De repente, conoceréis la salsa
y la salsa los hará libres,
de repente yo leía textos sobre
la salsa y parecía que la gente
bailaba salsa, porque siempre lo
que querían era demostrar que se
sentían orgullosos de su
identidad y yo preguntaba,
¿esta gente fue a
un baile de salsa?
Yo nunca vi en los bailes de
salsa gente con banderitas,
con banderitas y pancartas
diciendo, ¡qué viva la identidad!
Era otra cosa, no sé.
Entonces, también a veces,
cuando las instituciones se
apropian de ciertos géneros,
de ciertos procesos, es porque
están movilizando una agenda que
tiene que ver más con los hábitos
disciplinarios de la institución,
que con lo que estaba pasando.
Pero es cierto, yo quise tratar
de mantener a raya también eso,
no porque-- No quería
decir otra cosa,
sino para evitar quizás
cierta, sí,
cierta animosidad,
lo de la creencia.
Bueno, eso es algo que
todavía yo no tengo resuelto.
No es algo que yo tengo resuelto.
Con Benítez Rojo y yo en realidad
estoy de acuerdo contigo Juan,
con lo que tú me dices, más que
con la magia, a mí lo que yo--
Me doy cuenta hoy es que creo que
el proyecto de Benítez Rojo es una
especie de teorización real
maravillosa sobre el Caribe.
Y no es tanto lo que representa,
y lo que representa la magia,
sino el lugar que se coloca él,
donde se coloca él para
lidiar con esta situación.
Yo creo que ahí también hay una
suerte de homenaje a cómo él como
narrador, hace teoría, ¿no?
Entonces, la feminización,
porque en "La isla que se repite",
las feminizaciones son muy
fuertes y además muy violentas,
van por ahí, ¿no?
Más que por la creencia, sería
cierto tipo de creencia religiosa,
no la creencia en general.
Pero es algo que yo,
digamos, sigo pensando.
Y-- Y es algo que, yo no
podría decir que lo tengo
completamente resuelto.
>> Quería comentar algo.
>> Sí.
>> Sí, yo creo que este
es un tema para discutir,
esto es una cosa que queda abierta.
Lo que yo concedo y
tú demuestras ahí,
es que Benítez Rojo está colocando
como fundamento de autorización
posiblemente una-- Lo que él
llama una magia caribeña--
Entonces, ahí es cómo él lo
usa, lo está usando precisamente,
para cosas que no necesariamente
requieren tanta magia.
>> Además, tú sabes que
la bomba no cayó en Cuba,
no por el polvillo dorado y el olor
a albahaca y las piernas de las
negras, es que se pusieron a
hablar del [inaudible] con Kennedy.
[ Risas ]
>> Yo lo interpreté, yo
interpreté que el caminar--
O sea, eso cuando yo lo leí,
yo interpreté que el caminarle
enseñó a él que no había que
sentirse apocalíptico,
pero no interpreté que ese
caminar evitó la guerra.
Pero, de todas maneras, tampoco yo
quisiera como dar a entender que
estoy reivindicando la magia como la
liberación o la vida para ponerse a
ser brujos por ahí, porque lo que
sí quiero exponer es que no hay
razón ni siquiera para
una cosa ni para la otra,
porque la magia es un
procedimiento como todos,
son procedimientos que se
usan con tal o cual finalidad,
con tal o cual resultado y
eso depende de muchas cosas.
La gente lo dice por ahí,
tienen toda la razón,
hay magia [inaudible],
cómo decir, para el mal.
Trabaja para el mal.
Yo trabajo para el bien, y eso
es verdad, o sea, hay de todo.
Entonces, no es eso.
Y hay también protocolos
científicos malos,
y protocolos científicos
buenísimos, ¿no?
Entonces, eso era, como yo quiero
también entonces en mi lenguaje,
yo también como tú dices, me
gusta escribir como una peleíta
contra alguien.
En este caso, era contra ti,
pero te voy a confesar que era
contra cierta tendencia que veo por
ahí, que se plantea como
contraria a la identidad,
pero reivindicando
una cosa parecida,
que es volver a reivindicar
el giro lingüístico y eso.
Que es un poco la gente de Moreiras.
Entonces, eso a mí me, me da
como una cosa por dentro, ¿no?
Y eso era a lo que yo metí y
los demonios, sí, los demonios.
Y es lo que yo metí ahí
a escribir como con ganas.
Pero sí-- Estoy de acuerdo contigo
que son cosas para discutirse y que
eso es muy complicado.
>> Sobre el asunto de
"La isla que se repite",
tú le das duro a "La
isla que se repite".
Alguien una vez me preguntó cómo
yo traduciría al inglés el título
"La isla que se repite" y yo muy
burlonamente le dije The Island
that burps.
[ Risas ]
>> Porque repetir es
repetir la comida.
Es decir, sería una
traducción gástrica, ¿no?
Pero también como efecto de lo que
podría ser una mala digestión.
Y esa sería una manera de regresar
a Pales y esa supuesta metáfora
digestiva del Caribe,
que en Pales se poetiza.
Y que desaparece del
escenario de Benítez Rojo,
porque lo que ocupa ese
lugar es el de cierta manera.
Y yo creo que, yo estoy
muy de acuerdo contigo,
en que el de cierta manera--
No es que se repita infinitum como
sería en el reino de la diferencia
radical, sino que el cierta manera
es más una manera cierta que una
cierta manera.
Que hay una especie de certeza
metafísica que se tiende a ver como
el resultado esperado
de la repetición.
Ahora, lo que a mí más me
molesta de "La isla que se repite",
no es el de cierta manera,
si no la teoría del caos.
Yo encuentro que, el hecho de que
él haya sentido necesario escribir
un ensayo adicional al final del
texto para explicarle a todo el
mundo lo que es la teoría
del caos, me parece a mí,
como tú dices con dureza,
que delata el hecho de estratégico
de un intelectual que abandona su
lugar de origen y tiene que
averiguar dónde va a conseguir
trabajo, ¿no?
Entonces, yo creo que las dos
opciones del libro son, por un lado,
la mitología de la cierta
manera y, por otro lado,
la entelequia postmoderna
académica de la teoría del caos.
Una de estas dos cosas me va a
conseguir a mí un buen trabajo en
una universidad acreditada.
Y no lo estoy diciendo--
Qué sé yo,
porque yo me sienta
superior a ellos.
Todos hacemos nuestras movidas
para sobrevivir en los mercados,
entre otros de los
muchos, de la academia.
Lo que eso implica es
que, de cierta manera,
"La isla que se repite"
es un aparato también,
es como una especie de dispositivo
complejo que está con un pie en la
academia norteamericana, ya en ese
momento de la biografía de Antonio
Benítez Rojo y con otro pie en
la Cuba que él estaba a punto
de abandonar.
>> Rapidito.
Juan, Juan es de los primeros en
reseñar "La isla que se repite".
>> Que se repite.
>> Con un título de "Europa
piensa y el Caribe come".
>> Y el Caribe come, sí.
>> ¿No? Entonces, Juan
con mucha generosidad,
pero también con mucha ferocidad,
reconocía que aquí había otra
vez unas decantaciones éticas y
políticas muy burdas.
Por ejemplo, lo de la naturaleza,
la naturaleza siempre está como
sublimando o la naturaleza como que
sana al hombre, o sea, no hay
violencia en la naturaleza.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Sí. Y es como sanación, es una
manera de exorcizar la violencia.
Y yo no sé, yo creo que la
naturaleza es muy violenta también.
Entonces, había algo que, por
ahí, que yo un poco me fui,
más que como un ataque a la magia.
>> No es madre naturaleza,
es la madrastra naturaleza.
>> Bueno, como todos los
platillos deliciosos,
nos tiene que dejar deseando.
Entonces, vamos a parar
aquí, por favor,
porque les recuerdo que estamos
en la Biblioteca del Congreso,
que esto es parte del
Gobierno Federal y cierra,
cierra a las cinco de la tarde.
Entonces, si queremos en realidad,
que Juan Carlos nos
firme los libros,
si queremos comprar el ejemplar de
este libro, tenemos aproximadamente,
unos 15, 20 minutos antes de que
tengamos que abandonar el recinto,
porque nos cierran el
estacionamiento y nos cierran
el edificio.
Entonces, otra vez, un millón
de gracias a Rubén, a Juan,
a los dos Juanes, y a todos
ustedes por estar aquí.
Y adelante, vayan a
buscar ese libro.
[ Aplausos ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.